the Cleveland Browns this week signed
Kareem Hunt the former Kansas City chief
who was released during last season when
a video came out of him
assaulting a woman this is big news this
is big news for Cleveland fans and
football in general you know what I mean
cuz Cleveland has really really upgraded
at the kicker position
you know janakowski was the number one
guy Vinatieri was the number one guy for
a while and then they've kind of faded
out Janikowski might never play a game
again even and Terry's doing one last
season he's gone but now the best kicker
in the league I think it's Kareem hunt
once he gets back right well there's a
suspension looming sure he's supposed to
miss the beginning of the season so so
how does this play out you know with
their current kicker Greg Joseph
I think Joseph's gone I think who's
gonna kick early in the season they're
gonna go 4-2 they're gonna be going for
go important on fourth down
because once cream gets in there I don't
know how much our football ways but it
weighs less than a 21 year old girl so I
think he I think he could go from 60 I
think in a dome he could go from 70 and
really knock that they might change the
rules on on how field goes work they
might move the post back you know I make
it thinner because cream hunt is gonna
be kicking the bejesus out of more than
just women when he gets back on the
field for the Cleveland Browns I I don't
know he could he could change the game
any and you watch the it's gonna be
touch back City you you watched the AFC
North closely any concern you know the
windy condition like not an easy place
to kick Cleveland Pittsburgh Baltimore
am I worried about him like missing from
the right of the left laugh you've seen
his aim but he I mean as long as the
ball is on the floor like that girl was
then what's the problem
okay I don't care which way the wind is
blowing he's gonna kick it he's gonna
kick it I think he might honestly he
could be the highest-scoring he could be
the highest scorer in the league next
year even even after missing a chunk of
his season people people think he might
miss you know 68 games which is why a
lot of there was a lot of surprise
about the timing of this like not only
are you giving him a spot back in the
league so quickly and okay second
chances yada yada but they were like the
Browns were essentially racing to get
him signed before any other team could
do it they didn't wait they didn't do
anything I know you look at people
compared to Ray Rice you know what Ray
Rice just slapped his wife unconscious
he didn't reveal a new set of skills you
know cream hunt as a running back I
don't know I don't know if you put him
back in the league after what he did but
when you add that he's like likes to
kick and has a tremendous kick or I
don't know how you don't do that I think
if like honestly if cream hunt was on
the peanuts and Lucy put the ball down
he's kicking them both through the
uprights
one more headline Gregg and this one not
as like much fun and why Davi as the as
the last one
I'm sure I'm pronouncing that
incorrectly schwa Davi I don't even know
what it means but I know I said it right
the second time what's our last headline
of the day our last night align comes
from Harlem where a New York man is
facing charges of criminal mischief
after breaking a storefront window with
a cinder block to attack a Barack Obama
mannequin and here's my favorite part of
the story Greg what's the name of the
lingerie shop
romantic Depot yes this is hilarious
this guy is just walking by and Obama
has not been president for quite some
time but he's also he's been not
president long enough that you can make
a sexy mannequin of him that barely
looks like him and drape it in lingerie
and stick it in romantic Depot and this
guy wasn't gonna put up with that that
kind of in-your-face politics that he
had to break the window and gave the
gave the Obama mannequin a bit of a
beating so much so that a crowd formed
and tried to kick him because they were
so upset and people are like he was a
they're people Pro Obama people we're
fighting this guy I was like I think if
you just saw a guy smash a window with a
cinder block on the street and start
tearing up your neighborhood that you
would fight him for that I'm sure people
weren't like oh look
see that that that torso of a mannequin
on the street that's Obama well right
especially I really like that they they
talked about kind of a crowd of pro
Obama people surrounding it's like what
is a a crowd of pro Obama people what
are they like really like cool and
calculated and rational yeah like
there's like an alarm that goes off and
people were just like oh my god is like
a an effigy of the Obama and lingerie is
being kicked around we got to go do
something they're like they're like you
know in honor of Obama they like calmly
rash you know they calmly assess the
situation and then make practical
decisions and what they're gonna do next
mm-hmm-hmm yeah people were people are
upset but it didn't look anything like
Obama it looked like a 25 year old guy
like who you know is going out clubbing
in Chelsea like them the mannequin it
kind of reminds me have you guys ever
seen a curry probably too young have you
ever seen the movie mannequin yeah I
think I've seen a moment second movie
Kim Cattrall plays the mannequin who
plays the place the guy is one of the
brat pack dudes Andrew McCarthy
yes Andrew McCarthy plays the guy he's
walking by a store and Kim controls a
mannequin and she comes to life and he
smashes the window with a cinder block
drags her out on the street and kicks
the hell out of her and then a mob of
Kim Cattrall fans come and and stop them
it's it's a great movie mannequin 2 is
not as good but if mannequin want is it
really was a mannequin - yeah
yeah because mannequin I think was rated
on mannequin - was pg-13 I used to watch
it all the time on HBO
it was one of those movies that was on
all the time and I watched a lot well I
liked you know for a little more context
there was an Obama mannequin next to
like a Trump mannequin and this guy who
threw the cinder block and there's video
of the entire thing it looks like he
just kind of walks by sees it and then
like gets really angry and then just
there just happens to be a cinder block
like five feet away that he goes picks
up and throws through the through the
window he said he's a pro Trump guy and
he thinks Obama ruined the country but
my favorite detail was he said he was
hearing than the mannequin the Obama
mannequin speak to him
and he didn't like what Obama was saying
was the Trump mannequin speaking to him
- like what they were both taught they
were having a conversation he just like
interrupted I think I think I think the
Obama mannequin was speaking to the guy
walking by kind of like you're in the
wrong part of town buddy or something
I'd like what do you think the about a
mannequin was saying he's probably like
you can't afford this lingerie that I'm
wearing you know I mean he's probably
like hey I bet you like this but you'll
never have it I'm married to Michelle
and he just lost it
like what kind of lingerie were either
one of those mannequins wearing Trump or
a bomb like what were they was it like
silk boxers where they like totally done
up like wearing drawers and panties at
romantic Depot because if have you ever
been to romantic Depot in Harlem I mean
all shapes and sizes they can cover
everything but say you know what go to
Victoria's Secret if you want to if you
want to fight Obama in lingerie I like
that the store manager at the end of the
article as an aside was like she
believes the assailant was it was
mentally ill I was like do you think the
Obama laundry I was talking to him you
think he's little he's in trouble
listen I've walked by lingerie I've like
walked by lingerie mannequins I thought
we're talking to me but I kept walking
yeah I mean you don't to break the
window and where did he find the cinder
block that's that's part of the G the
amazing thing of the video he walks by
he sees it he kicks he kicks at Obama
and then he walks like to two more steps
and then just to his left he sees like a
little fence he pushes it to the side
picks up a cinder block that just
happens to be sitting there throws it
through the window like just was there
here's what we're gonna end on this this
is great because this guy takes a cinder
block smashes the storefront window
pulls out a mannequin of Obama which I
don't even know they make those pulls it
out beats it up how much is he charged
like how much what's the damages
somewhere between 250 and thousand
dollars
that's a $250 I was like man romantic
depos got to get it together maybe they
just have great insurance on their Obama
mannequin but like you would think
that's like that's not a lot of money
like if you were like Santa you can say
this just went over to 50 I would smash
every window I walked by
[Music]
you